ونحييكم الى تفاصيل النقاش الاول استكمالا
للمساع الراميه لعوده العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه عادت ايران فتحه مقر سفارتها في
العاصمه الرياض وذلك استكمالا لتنفيذ
الاتفاقيات بين ايران والسعوديه ممثلون عن
وزارتي الخارجيه السعوديه والايرانيه
حضروا الافتتاح في مقر السفاره الايرانيه
الذي كان مغلقا لسنوات بعد ان تم الترميمه
بالكامل مؤخرا اتت هذه الخطوه بعدما اعلنت
وسائل اعلام ايرانيه بان الدبلوماسي رفيعا
مستوى علي رضا عنايه سيكون السفير الجديده
في الرياض كما اتى الافتتاح بعد ثلاثه
اشهر من توقيع الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
لاستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما
برعايه صينيه وكذلك بعد ان تبادل البلدان
في ابريل الماضي زياره لوفدين فنيين من
اجل بحث مساله اعاده فتح السفارات
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين طهران والرياض
العاشر من مارس عام 2023 بيان مشترك سعودي
ايراني باعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
الطرفين اهم بنود البيان استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين اعاده فتح سفارتي
البلدين والممثليتين بمده اقصاها شهرا
احترام الجانبين سياده الدول اعاده تفعيل
اتفاقيتين ابرمهما البلدان للتعاون في
المجالات الاقتصاديه عام
1998 والامنيه عام 2001
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الرياض جسر
الجسر الكاتب الصحفي وبعد قليل سينضم لنا
كذلك من طهران دكتور محمد صالح صادق يا
مدير المركز العربي للدراسات الايرانيه
ارحب بكم وسابدا معك استاذ جاسر استاذ
جاسر في الواقع هذا التطور هو خطوه مهمه
في مسار توطيد العلاقات بين البلدين بين
السعوديه وايران ما الذي يمثله اليوم
الحديث عن استرجاع سفاره ايران في الرياض
وتنصيب سفير
مساء الخير اليوم انا اعتقد النقطه المهمه
انه يعني لناقل انه اتفاق بكين
الاتفاقات التفاصيل الداخليه غير المعلنه
التي تم نقاشتها والتي تم من خلالها بلوره
هذه الفتره الزمنيه اللي شهران لدع
استئناف العلاقات يبدو انها تسير في
المسار الصحيح ويبدو ان هناك تناغما او
اتفاقا على كثير من النقاط ادت الى هذه
النتيجه طبيعيه وهذه عم بشر نحن وصلنا
قطعنا يعني الطريق لنقل المثل اللي كانت
الفتره التي كانت حرجه وقلقه ومظلمه هل
سيكون هناك التزام لن يكون هناك التزام
هناك اختلافا يبدو انه كثير من التفاصيل
هذه احلت بشكل ايجابي وبتعاون وهذا اليوم
تاتي استكمالا واعلان لمرحله الجديده صحيح
لا يعتبر حتى الان هو كان الاتفاق شهرين
لا يعتبر هذا تاخير لانه خلال فتره
الماضيه نقول انه كانت عمليات الترميم
واستعاده وتجهيز المكاتب فبالتالي بدايه
جدا مرحله الان نحن نقر او نقول انه نعم
في نقل نوعيه ستحدث في مسار العلاقات ليس
فقط بين البلدين لكن في المنطقه ككل
وسيتغير المشهد بشكل كبير كما هو حتى
تعيين عنايتي حقيقه يعني هو جانب ايضا
اهتمام بان يكون الممثل الايراني السفير
الايراني هو من شخصيه رفيعه ومهمه لتاكيد
التواصل المستمر والتعاون والعمل المشترك
خلال الفتره المقبله واعاده بناء الاسس
التي يمكن من خلالها الوصول الى اتفاقات
اكثر وضوحا واكثر دقه طيب خلينا نسال في
نفس هذا الاطار ضيفنا من طهران الدكتور
صادق دكتور صادقين ضيف يقول بانه
بفتح السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض قطعنا
شوط مهم في توطيد العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه طبعا تتفق معه او بقيه الطريق
لازال كذلك يشمل بعض النقاط الجد مهمه
لمحاوله تقريب وجهه النظر بين الطرفين
والمشاهدين الان يعتقد بان هذه الخطوه هي
في غايه الاهميه وبالتالي فتح السفارات
لدى البلدين تضع اللبنه الاساسيه من اجل
تطوير هذه العلاقات يعني نحن لا نتحدث
الان عن
مجرد فتح سفارات واعطاء تاشيرات دخول
لرعايه البلدين نحن نتحدث عن تعاون وتنسيق
بين البلدين في المجالات
المختلفه سواء كانت السياسيه الامنيه
الاقتصاديه خصوصا وان تفاهمات بكين نصت
على تفعيل
اتفاقيتين مهمتين بين البلدين الاتفاقيه
الاولى التي وقعت في عام 1998 وهي
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه التعاون الشامله بين
البلدين واتفاقيه الثانيه والاتفاقيه
الاهم التي وقعت في العام 2001 هي
الاتفاقيه الامنيه الموقعه بين البلدين
نحن نتطلع الى تفعيل هات الاتفاقيتين من
اجل احتضان اي تفاهمات وربما ان تكون بين
البلدين وبالتالي فتح السفاره الايرانيه
في الرياض والقنصليه في جده وفتح السفاره
السعوديه في في طهران ان يعتقد من شانهم
ايجاد يعني سؤال واسمح لي ان اطرح عليك
هذا السؤال سؤال شيطاني قليلا ليس لطيف
طرحه في مثل هكذا اجواء ايجابيه ولكن
لماذا بدانا او بدانا او تبعنا فتح
السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض ولم يتزامى
ذلك مع فتح السفاره السعوديه في طهران
البعض يقول بانه الاجواء في طهران لا زالت
اجواء مرتبكه وعدم قدره طهران على تامين
المؤسسات الدبلوماسيه السعوديه لا زال
هناك نقاط استفهام حول ذلك ما رايك دكتور
انا لا حقيقه يعني هذا السؤال الذي وصفتيه
بالشيطاني انا حقيقه لا امتلك معلومات
بهذا الشان وربما يكون هناك بعض
النيه البسيطه يعني انا اصفها بسيطه لان
لماذا بسيطه لانه هناك قرار اهم من ذلك
وهو اعاده فتح السفارات هذا القرار هو
المهم الان هناك نقاط اشكالات ربما
اشكالات بسيطه والجزئيه وتفصيليه
والشيطان يدخل في التفاصيل كما يقولون لكن
بشكل عام ان يعتقد بان حتى مجالات او
اجواء فتح السفاره السعوديه في طهران هي
اجواء ايجابيه وهناك قرار لدى القياده
القياده السياسيه في ايران من اجل
تعزيز العلاقه بين الجانبين وبالتالي يجب
علينا ان
نتذكر بان من
وقع على اعاده العلاقات بين البلدين هو
مندوب للمرشد الايراني لا لا يعني مندوب
للرجل الاول في القياده السياسيه في ايران
وبالتالي اعتقد بانه هناك وهناك حتى كلام
بان المرشد الايراني على نفسه هو الذي دعم
ودفع بهكذا مسار تقاربي استاذ جاسر طيب
عوده السفارات ماذا بعد هناك كذلك رهانات
عديده هناك اسئله عديده وهناك ملفات ولكن
ما الملفات الاوليه ما الملفات الاهم في
موضوع تقارب السعوديه وايران
انا اسمي دائما فتح العلاقات العلاقات مثل
سباق التتابع هو قائم على مراحل ننهي خطوه
نبدا في الخطوه الاخرى وكل خطوه مرتبطه
بما سبقها انا اعتقد ان الاتفاقيه الامنيه
تحديدا الذي ذكرت الدكتور محمد انا اعتقد
انه نفذت بعض الاجراءات العمليه على الارض
التي كانت مؤشرا للوصول الى مرحله فتح
السفارات هناك يعني تشكل تفاهم وعمل مشترك
بين الطرفين لحل اشكالات معينه لنقل
النقاط الحرجه والاكثر
فيها الظرف هذه مرحله المرحله الثانيه
لنشهد هناك اصبح الفتره الاخيره تقارب
يعني اللقاءات
بالهيان مع الامير فيصل وفي اكثر من مره
واخرها في
يعني في زياره يوم كانوا في مجموعه بريكس
اللقاء ايضا الوزير الصحه الايراني مع
وزير الصحه السعودي لقاء مع وزير الماليه
السعودي الجدعان في صار هناك نشا فعلا نوح
حوار اذا متطلبات نعمل على نعود الى
البيان الاساسي المطلوب نعم ماذا سنعمل
اولا اللي هو عدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه تفعيل اتفاقيه الامنيه وحل
الاشكالات القائمه في بنودها مثلا اللي هو
التعاون على مواجهه الارهاب التهريب
المخدرات يعني
ملاحقته الكوادر التي تحاول ان تشرفتنالي
في هناك خطوات عمل الملامح المحوريه التي
اراها الان واللي تعطي مؤشرات ايجابيه
وتؤكد نمضي في مسار واضح ان افاق واوسع
بشكل كبير
هناك نوع صحيح تاخذ وقت معين لكن لانه
يعني لنقل ان المستثمرين السعوديين سواء
شركات او او جهات حكوميه تحتاج وقت الى
استكشاف ايران لانها ظلت طوال السنوات هذه
بيئه مجهوله وغامضه ليس من السهل عقد
اتفاقات سريعه لكن المداولات والزيارات
واللقاءات والاجتماعات والمشاريع
الافتراضيه المطروحه تؤكد اذا دخل
الاقتصاد بهذه القوه يعني معناته يعني ان
هناك بنيه صلبه تقوم عليها العلاقات وان
خرجت من الاطارات الدبلوماسي والاشكال
والاعراف العامه الى العمل الحقيقي
الاقتصاد لا يمكن يكون له مؤشر ايجابيه
طبيعه راس المال لا يمكن ان يعيش في اجواء
قلقه ومخيفه ومرتبطه بس نضيف نقطه على
مساله السفر انا اعتقد انه اختلاف السفاره
فقط يمكن اشكاليه انه مباني السفاره
السعوديه في طهران بسبب ما تعرضت له سابقا
تحتاج الى اعاده تاهيل يعني اطول مدى من
السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض التي كانت
ضمن الحيه الدبلوماسي ولا ومغلقه ولم
تتعرض الى اذى في بنيتها الاساسيه وربما
ان ناقشكالات لجستيه لكن وفعلا عاده
العلاقات التفاصيل لفتح المبنى تاخر وفتح
المبنى تاخر مباشره السفير هي تظل تفاصيل
يعني لا تفرق كثيرا في هذا الجانب لانه
المبدا اقر واعتمد وبدات خطوات العمليه
طيب دكتور صدقين هل يمكن الحديث عن معادله
الامن مقابل
الاقتصاد بان تلتزم ايران بحل القضايا
الامنيه مقابل ان يكون هناك اطار تعاوني
استثماري اقتصادي هل ترى ايران الموضوع
بهذا الشكل او لها معادله او حسابات اخرى
يعتقد باننا يجب ان ننظر الى العلاقه
الايرانيه السعوديه من زاويه اخرى
البلدان بلدان مهمان كبيران استراتيجيان
في هذه المنطقه وفي المجتمع الدولي
وبالتالي الامن يخدم الاقتصاد والاقتصاد
يخدم الامن مثل ما قال صديقي في السعوديه
قال بانه يجب ان تكون هناك ارضيه صلبه
تستطيع ان تستوعب التفاهمات بين البلدين
وبالتالي الاقتصاد ان تكون هناك كذلك ليس
فقط ارضيه صلبه ولكن ارضيه امنه كذلك لان
المستثمر لما سيفكر في دخول طهران يجب ان
يفكر في ان يكون مستقبله مستقبل امن
مستقبل
قادر ان يؤمن به مؤسساته وعناصره كذلك
هذا صحيح جدا هناك تفصيلات في الوضع
الشركات الاستثماريه في ايران لكني اتحدث
عن البيئه بيئه المنطقه ككل والتفاهمات
الامنيه بين البلدين هذه التفاهمات
الامنيه بين البلدين يعني في الداخل
الايراني داخل امن للاستثمارات ضمن قوانين
وهذه القوانين ربما تعدل او بشكل الذي
تستطيع فيه الشركات السعوديه والعربيه ان
تستثمر في الداخل الايراني وفي المشاريع
الايرانيه لكن الاهم من ذلك هو التفاهمات
الامنيه في المنطقه لانه هناك اشكاليه في
ذلك وبالتالي انا اعتقد عندما يتحدث عن
الوضع لاني اتحدث عن التفاهمات الامنيه
بين البلدين وهذه تفاهمات الامنيه هي
التفاهمات الاقليميه
التعاون الاقتصادي يمكن ان يؤدي الى الى
اعطاء بعض الثقه نحن الان نتحدث ايضا عن
ثقه الثقه المفقوده بين البلدين هذه الثقه
مهمه عزيزي الثقه مهم للبلدين وبالتالي
يطرح الواقع نقطه مهمه دكتور صادقان هذه
الثقه من سيؤمنها وضع امن او وضع اقتصادي
مريح على كل هذه كانت مصافحه اولى تزامنا
مع فتح السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض
والاكيد باننا سنعود الى مجالات التعاون
ولكن في حلقه اخرى اول شكركم على المشاركه
من طهران الدكتور محمد صالح مدير المركز
العربي لدراسه الايرانيه ومن الرياض جسر
الجاسر الكاتب الصحفي شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات